PROFESSOR: The binomial
theorem extends
to a thing called the
multinomial theorem,
whereas instead of taking a
product of a sum of two things,
you'd take the product
of a sum of k things
to get the multinomial theorem.
And what underlies it
is a rule that we're
going to call the bookkeeper
rule, and here's why.
So, the bookkeeper rule
is about the question of,
look at the word bookkeeper
and ask how many different ways
are there to scramble the
letters in this word that
actually are distinguishable?
The point being that the two
o's are indistinguishable,
so the order in which they
appear doesn't matter.
Likewise, the three
e's and the two k's.
Well, how do we
answer this question?
The simple way to
do it to begin with
is to label all of
the indistinguishable
letters with subscripts to
make them distinguishable.
So, I'm going to put subscripts
1 and 2 on the o's, 1 and 2
on the k's, and 1,
2, and 3 on the e's.
Now, all the 10 letters
are distinguishable.
And if I ask how
many ways are there
to permute these 10
letters, the answer,
we know by the
generalized product
rule is simply 10 factorial.
Now, my strategy is going
to be to use the division
rule to count the number
of patterns of the letters
in the word with no subscripts.
And the way I'm
going to do that is
take one of these subscripted
words and erase the subscripts.
So, I'm going to map it to the
same permutation of letters
with no subscripts.
I've just done that.
Here I've taken an
arbitrary permutation
of the subscripted word, and
then I've erased the subscripts
and consolidated the letters.
And I wind up with
this permutation.
Now, if I want to
count the number
of unsubscripted
permutations, then I simply
figure out that this
mapping is K to 1,
and I'm going to then divide by
K. Well, how many to 1 is it?
Well, how many subscripted
words map to this given pattern?
The answer is the subscripts
on the o's don't matter,
so there's two possible orders
in which those subscripts might
appear.
Subscripts on the
k's don't matter.
There's two possible
orders in which
those subscripts might appear.
Subscripts on the
e's don't matter.
Three possible orders, or 3
factorial possible orders that
the subscripts might
occur in the e's.
The net result is that with
two o's, two k's, and three
e's, the mapping is 2
factorial by 2 factorial
by 3 factorial to 1.
And that instantly gives
us, by the division rule,
that the total number
of permutations
of the letters in
the word bookkeeper
is 10 factorial over 2 factorial
times 2 factorial times 3
factorial.
More generally by
the same reasoning
if, I look at a sequence of
n letters, of which n1 are
a's and n2 are b's up
through nk are z's, then
the number of permutations
of those letters
with the repeated
a's, b's, and Z's is
n factorial divided
by n1 factorial times
n2 factorial through
nk factorial.
And this formula occurs so
often that it has a name.
It's called a
multinomial coeff--
there's a name for it
written in this format,
n over n1, n2 through nk.
You could start to say n
choose n1 choose n2 choose nk,
if you're thinking
about how we pronounce
the binomial coefficients.
The convention is that the
sum of the ni's is supposed
to be equal to the numerator n.
This is called a
multinomial coefficient.
So, n factorial divided by
this product of factorials
is written in somewhat
shorter notation
without the factorials as
a multinomial coefficient.
Binomial coefficient, by
the way, are a special case.
When we write n choose
k, if we wrote it
as a multinomial
coefficient, you'd
have to write it as n choose
k and then choose n minus k.
So, we can apply this to think
about words and coefficients
and expanding things that
are more than binomials.
So, let's look at expanding
a quintomial, a sum of five
things, E, M, S, T,
and Y. And I raise that
to the seventh power.
So, that means in these products
of seven of these terms,
I'm looking at words
of length seven
whose components are the
letters E, M, S, T, and Y.
And So, if I multiply this out,
applying the distributive law,
I would wind up with
5 to the 7th terms,
each of them consisting of
a permutation of the letters
E, M, S, T, and Y.
And if I ask what's the
coefficient in that expansion
of the term E, M,
S cubed, T, Y, it's
exactly the number of ways
of permuting these five
letters, a word of length seven
made out of these five letters
with three occurrences
of S. In other words,
the coefficient of E, M, S
cubed, T, Y in this product
is the number of ways of
rearranging the letters
in this sequence of seven.
It's the word
systems, which is why
we chose it to be rememberable.
How many ways are
there to rearrange
the letters in the word
systems by the bookkeeper rule?
There are seven.
Choose 1, 1, 3, 1, 1.
Let's do another example.
What's the coefficient
of BA cubed
N squared if I expand
this trinomial, B plus A
plus N to the sixth power?
Well, now again I have
3 to the 6th terms.
How many of them involve
a B, three A's, and two
N's by the bookkeeper rule?
It's the number of
ways-- well, it's
the number of ways
of rearranging
the letters in the word banana.
And by the bookkeeper
rule, that's
six with subscripts 1, 3, and 2.
More generally, this is what
the multinomial theorem says.
If I look at the
coefficient of the term--
a product of Xi to the
ri's in an expansion
of a k-nomial, a sum of k
distinct variables raised
to the n-th power, now
I've got if I expanded this
out using the distributive
law without collecting terms,
I'd have k to the n
terms, each of which
was a permutation of the X1's
through Xk's, with repeats.
And then if I ask, how
many of those products,
if any of these k variables
have this many X1's, this many
X2's, through this many rk's--
this many Xk's, I'm asking
again a bookkeeper question.
And the answer is n
choose r1, r2 through rk.
So, now we're ready
for the record
to state the general
multinomial formula.
If I take a sum of k terms,
a k-nomial to the nth power,
then expressing it
in concise notation,
it's the sum over r1 through rk
summing to n of the multinomial
coefficient n r1 through rk
times this product of Xi's.
I'm not putting a
highlighted box around it,
because this is not a
formula which is particularly
important to memorize.
And it's clearly all
clogged up with subscripts.
But nevertheless, it's good to
have sometimes for the record.
And next week, we will
continue with this theme
about the connection between
counting and algebra.
And in particular, not
only ordinary polynomials
as we've been looking at
here with a product of sums,
but in fact, infinite
polynomials or infinite series
when we pick up generating
functions next week.